Shyne for annual here on Halloween okay
zero the next time GM gives a World
Series MVP a pickup truck they should
make sure it hasn't been recalled
because the one they just gave madison
bumgarner Ernie was huh
either that or make an ad that goes you
just won the World Series where are you
going next through the windshield new
rule the women in the sexy zombie or
sexy vampire costumes have to tell the
women in the sexy corn costume that
Monsanto is real and some things are too
scary to make sexy new role now that
I've seen the video of the woman in New
York City being harassed over a hundred
times a day scientists must explained
why the men with the most
self-confidence are always the ones with
the least to offer Hey Baby you want to
come back to my place
it's a dumpster right over there I'll
let you have a sip of whatever is in
this can I found new rule nurse kaci
Hickox has to explain one simple
question if you're so non-contagious
how come your senator is sending 3,000
miles away here with me
you didn't meet her did you
and government officials must calm down
and look at this logically its main the
best the best quarantine policy is
there's nowhere to go anyway come on I
love May I was in Portland this year
neuro kim jeonghun must lend his
binoculars to his barber that haircut
doesn't say supreme leader of the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea it
says house party sequel